I've seen people saying things like the
sun doesn't cause skin cancer it's
actually sunscreen this is an example of
correlation getting mixed up with
causation all three are correlated
because the sun does cause sunscreen use
but we have evidence that doesn't have
this problem scientific experiments
where the variables are controlled for
example this clinical trial we have
people in the same location similar ages
similar skin color only sunscreen use
has changed half the people wore
sunscreen every day consistently the
other half wore less sunscreen only when
they wanted to if sunscreen cause skin
cancer then the people who wore more
sunscreen should have more skin cancer
but if the Sun causes skin cancer they
would have less guess what more
sunscreen meant less skin cancer their
skin also looked younger so that's nice
here's another experiment different
amounts of sunscreen was applied before
blasting skin with a lamp that gives the
same light as the sun then they look for
thymine diamonds which is messed up DNA
this is the first step towards skin
cancer taller bar means more messed up
DNA the tallest bar was for no sunscreen
the more sunscreen there was the less
messed up the DNA got